let's pull up this clip we got this
tweet from Mr Luke gradkowski himself
yes MSNBC is behind my idea fetterman
Biden 2024. Ketterman as a nominee at
some point for president
um I know there's some variables
obviously but it's just a few but I just
you know
what he did in the in the super red deep
red parts of Pennsylvania and the way
that he ran ahead of Biden as you were
saying ran ahead of trump I mean it just
makes it makes you wonder about his
future okay uh I'm sorry if you read
hold on hold on hold on fetterman in the
Senate as a Democrat I can understand
why there's why you know there's a
there's a closed door but open window
there for the next two years Democrats
are going to have to answer for a man
who's not all with it who's got brain
damage in the Senate and it's going to
be amazing talking points for
Republicans but fetterman as the
president no no no no there's nothing
after that I mean you want to sacrifice
the country for four years so that you
can try and win after the that I I'm
sorry I'm not on board I'm I'm messaging
my guys right now we're making
officially Biden fetterman 2024 shirts
that are going to be available on the
best political shirts right now probably
by the end of tonight sorry go ahead no
it's it's um
you know a lot of folks think that maybe
moving fetterman into that position was
a way of putting his wife in position uh
that he's going to become you know here
in the next I don't know less than six
months he's going to be unable to
perform his duties or whatever after
he's sworn in and it puts his wife in a
position to fill his fill his seat uh
we'll see I mean either way you're
dealing with insanity
across the board I mean you're dealing
with Insanity with this thing the fact
that they they looked at a guy and you
know you look at the memes the fetterman
means I put one on my Facebook earlier
today and people said you know this is
way beneath you and I'm like you have no
idea what's beneath me you don't know
how low I can go but uh they said you're
making you have no sympathy for a stroke
victim I mean my father ultimately died
from his stroke so I it's not when I'm
making fun of his Strokes he was a [ __ ]
before he had a stroke uh and again if
if he's a stroke victim then his family
should have had sympathy and never put
him up there they should have pulled him
off that platform like if he's that
impaired that he can't he's a senator
for Christ's sake if he's a senator and
uh he can't handle some ridicule or a
meme about him then what the hell are we
doing I think they just like electing
people that they can control well it's
100 though absolutely like like that
that guy in Pennsylvania who was dead
yeah I said are we supposed to have
sympathy for the dead God too well and
what about the person that was running
against them like do they not
I'm surprised the Democrats didn't dig
them up and like hey
put his hand on the Bible I recently
learned that you can't defame dead
people so now we can say Democrats
elected fraudsters con artists and
rapists oh they're dead you can't defame
them no I don't want to disparage the
the people who died I got no beef they
say oh you have no sympathy for a guy
well I have no sympathy for the person
that's dead either they're dead but I
mean you still elected them Hugh McKean
apparently died and was elected and then
Barbara Cooper she died in October
but seriously to the person that ran
against them they lost to a dead person
what do you do what do you do next
that's worse than us like that's pretty
embarrassing well you if you're dead if
you are dead your votes should be
eliminated period just gone right don't
know don't care there should no special
election your votes are gone if you vote
for a dead person your vote is gone you
voted for a dead person you're punished
like imagine you're playing basketball
somebody and you throw the ball just out
of the Court okay that that's your
that's a foul or something what is that
out of court or whatever no yeah out of
bounds we don't give you points for it
we don't say hold on let's let's let's
let's start over again and we'll figure
this out no no no you you screwed up
that's right and I understand that after
a certain point like if you die after a
certain point you you name there's a
good chance you'll be on the ballot our
good friend Serge Summers he died in the
middle of his campaign oh my God you
voted for it I voted you voted for it so
let's call you out on that I'm a
hypocrite he's a good friend of ours and
you gave him a little honor it's bad I
didn't he didn't but he died on the
campaign Trail he died in a car wreck I
got to read this super chat from James K
James this was a grand slam he says
Biden fetterman 2024 it's a no-brainer
that
was real good anyway on to the dead
people who won
um amazing
congratulations y'all so what is it I
mean look Republicans have elected dead
people before too because people will
like these guys some two of these
Democrats I think they died in October
or you know at least one of them did and
so people maybe just didn't realize the
person died like they knew who the
person was maybe they or I got to be
honest I think they just show up they
hit the D and they walk out oh yeah
that's probably true they don't know who
they're voting for well a friend of mine
he got Biden that calls out for dead
people yeah well I mean yeah oh man he
did I mean I think I think Biden's at
that stage in life where his his toes
were on the precipice of the Eternal so
he's already seeing into you know the
nether regions and he's just seeing
people there floating around and he was
there yeah he didn't want to see if
she's there yeah where is she is she
here well you see he's trying to shake
hands with the air all the time yeah
yeah this is he's got his toes are the
president of Eternity yeah
this is uh shout out to Sheamus of
Freedom Tunes this is a good it's a good
horror uh uh bit Biden's so close to the
other side that he's starting to see
whatever you know the thing uh but I've
got a friend who said he was at the
polling place and he goes up to the uh
the voting deal and he puts his thing in
it there's two girls young girls that
are standing there and one of the girls
says I don't know who any of these
people are I don't know what to do and
the girl beside her said just vote
Democrat
and that goes right back to your point
like if you're gonna do that stay home I
mean our country went from you've got to
be a landowner you had the man voted for
the household I mean there were certain
requirements that you had and now you've
got any person that's brain dead out
there casting a vote because that's what
they're doing and I remind people voting
is not a right it is a privilege in this
country we have the rights that are that
afford US certain privileges you don't
have the right to vote you have the
privilege to vote it's it's a thing that
you should take very responsibly I mean
I might for instance I moved three
months ago four months ago from Fort
Worth Texas down to the Houston area I
changed my address changed everything
changed it with the secretary of state
to give me a new polling place I still
because the state did not change my
polling place I still had to go back to
Fort Worth Texas three and a half hours
from where I'm living now go back to
Fort Worth Texas and vote on Tuesday
election day and do it and listen I was
nervous because I thought I'm going to
get up here they're going to run my
driver's license and say well these
addresses don't match yeah I I still had
to fill out a form that said change of
address with the polling place and do it
so I I so again it's racist it's racist
that I had to do this but you know uh I
had to fill out another Form and I said
this this you're actually asking me to
write on this form the same things that
are on my driver's license why am I
doing this they said just do it I think
it should be harder to vote it should be
harder to vote I think voting is
it's a duty it's responsibility and it
is you saying I want certain things for
this for this country for the city for
this County whatever
the Democrat policy is let's just get as
many votes as possible we don't care
about the quality of the votes it gives
us power that's why they want 16 year
olds to vote right I think voting should
be hard but it should be this hard you
have to get up and go vote yeah
that's it yeah forget that drop forget
that mail in forget all of that so I
mean again if you're in firm your
military your law enforcement on duty
the stuff like that I understand there
are special concessions for that but the
guy that doesn't want to get up and go
should not vote no if you if if you
don't want to be there you shouldn't be
that's just the way it is
I mean it's frustrating to me tomorrow's
Veterans Day right I don't know when
this air is this we're live so this this
thing so we're Veterans Day tomorrow
right when you we went to Antietam today
we went we went over there and you go
over there 22
717 I think men died that day fighting
each other Americans fighting each other
you go to the graveyard and it is a sad
reminder not only brother against
brother Clash I mean that's the
bloodiest battle in the Civil War but
then you think about Normandy and you
think about you know the the millions
that died in the world wars and and you
look at the Afghanistan of evacuation
and the 13 that died there and that just
senseless stuff that goes on you're like
you got men and women that put on a
uniform every day with a willingness to
serve sacrifice give their lives for our
Liberty our freedom our ability to have
those privileges I mentioned and you
don't do it you just don't do it you
don't give a [ __ ] enough to go out there
and study and see what's best to protect
your freedoms these guys died they bled
they sacrificed they go on deployment
nine ten months out of the year to stay
away from their children and you go and
you don't you can't read a book you
can't Google something to see if John
fetterman's a
little idiot it's like you said people
had things have not gotten bad enough
for people to want to vote or to change
the way this is what happens when we
live in a world of manufactured
oppression and not real oppression
they've never suffered they've
manufactured victimhood they've told
themselves their victims and and they
haven't done without food they haven't
done without water I mean unless you
live in you know Mississippi Jackson
Mississippi and there's sludge coming
out of your faucet for two weeks but
they haven't done without and so now
what they're saying is oh I got it so
hard I can't go if you got it so hard
you can't go vote have you seen the
video of the Starbucks employee crying
about having to work yeah hours yeah it
was the funniest who's a trans
who's a trans person I don't know if you
caught that that was the other thing she
was complaining about was they were
misgendering and and that was the other
thing and which I think honestly was
probably the the Catapult that pushed
her into making the video anyway because
that was the stressor that was that was
the impression but you know and and
it the story wasn't about someone being
mean to this person it was just that
people kept misgenderings I grew my
beard on everything well I got to pass
I'm not I want to be careful because I
don't know if the individual was male
wanting to be a woman or a woman if a
woman want to be a male I mean you got
to assume you know she didn't
they didn't say so we don't really know
and she said I grew my beard out and
everything I think that was the quote Oh
okay but but the issue is so like look
at America right now you go across I
mean I travel the country I do I'm in 35
States a year doing live comedy shows
I'm all over the place 200 000 miles a
year in the air everywhere I go across
the country I was in Seattle last week
everywhere you go they went from having
Help Wanted signs outside of the
restaurants just saying please be
patient with our staff yep yep I saw
that uh it's a weird Trend if you think
about that I went to uh we were going
down to the Virginia Safari
and we drove through New Market it's
really cool when you're out here by the
way because all the Civil War histories
it's incredible yeah and we went to this
little restaurant and they had a big
sign saying please be patient with our
staff no one wants to work anymore no
joke I tweeted a picture of it out uh
take the picture and it's just it's it's
crazy to me I'm like where are all these
people where'd they go yeah did they get
raptured or something no no no they got
their checks in the mail now they don't
want to work well but they're not doing
that anymore so we went out uh several
times now uh a few weeks ago we went to
a theme park and it was the Halloween
party oh yeah completely dead yeah
completely empty 50 people maybe in this
theme park and we're just like what is
going on yeah like where is it okay
maybe more than maybe about 50 people I
think I saw and if you wanted to go on a
ride you had to go to the ride and there
was no one Manning it and then text a
phone number and someone would come and
press the ride button for you
Watson on you there's no shame in our
culture anymore nobody feels shame
nobody's ashamed of anything everyone's
proud there's no work ethic because
there's no shame in doing a poor job
thanks for watching this clip from the
timcast IRL podcast hang out with us
live Monday through Friday at 8 pm and
become a member over at timcast.com for
uncensored members only shows exclusive
thanks for hanging out and we'll see you
all next time